[Music]
I'm Tyler and I'm gonna save a little
more time this is your at-home Whiteside
workout today we've got a Whiteside
style full body cardio intensive workout
focused on weight loss or weight the
bags I see you got something there in
your pocket yes I mean as an instructor
and as a fighter in general a wrap in
your hands is probably one of the most
important and critical things that you
can do these they have a little more
surface area to wrap around of your
wrist
all right go ahead me two fists good
let's go ahead and check you good nice
stuff all right so now and also when it
comes to gloves I always try to suggest
for people who are new to boxing to go
with a heavier glove to have a little
more padding in general because just
gives you a little more ability to be a
little bit safer so we make sure we keep
that and wrist and they're nice and
tight if you don't have a bag you can do
the same thing you're still going to be
getting a workout
throw those punches with a little bit of
extra weight but we're gonna work on
just your basics okay the biggest thing
we want to work on is making sure you
stay in to your proper fighting stance
okay
okay you keep your hands up okay and
what you're gonna work on doing there
you go see you might come for just a
little tiny bit go ahead and how you got
there and cut it good touch there and
then we're gonna basically just work on
your left-right combination okay and as
you do that remember you cross your
hands okay so you're you're pushing your
punches out but your punches are not
coming from your upper body they're
coming from your hips okay so we're
gonna practice doing a three minute
round now what you want to do is count
the number of punches that you can throw
in three minutes
and then you can slowly progress your
way up and so we're gonna stick which is
basically boxing right now we're gonna
work on the basic one two which is left
right okay so just practice the one one
two at the back good and breathe you see
how the back moves a little bit you can
kind of wait till it cycles back and
adjust back to you
or if you're training with a partner
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
stand behind that bag and they're gonna
hold it good up four different ways you
can throw your knees when you're
practicing on the bag you can practice
it throwing them from from distance in
general where you're here and you're
slamming the bag waiting to come back or
I'm gonna start with my I'm gonna stay
in my fighting stance I'm gonna start
with my rear leg first okay and we can
do a double knee strike where that way
you can work both legs with a power
strike so what I would do is that drive
my first knee right here right in the
middle of the back bang now what I would
do is I would take this foot and step
straight down then I would take my back
leg and I'd shift that one back it's a
power like bang come straight in and
fire that knee up and then down and
shift back good and then you shift back
good good and really work on driving the
knee in there
so throw your punches then grab that
knee so bang bang grab now neat good
bang bang
grab nice with your feet perfect do it
again
now will really incorporate a little bit
of everything you're working your arms
you're working your knees okay
everything's coming from that core from
that middle part of your stomach but
last one good job we'll have you lack
shake your arms out make sure you
breathe no pain in your wrists no pain
the elbows good job good job
well guys to recap the first minute or
so we concentrated on some combos 1 2
etc then you can start throwing in some
of those knee strikes
finish it up with a couple of different
combo 1 twos and knee strikes and you
can do this for 3 minutes 5 minutes good
stuff man I appreciate it thank you make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any other fighting weight episodes
[Music]